my prince always look at that line up
around the corner hasn't even opened yet
was it worth waiting two hours maintain
a melting welcome to day five of the of
the Dallas adventure today we're gonna
explore Dallas and take you guys with us
[Music]
so we are on the hunt for the best
brisket best barbecue in Dallas we're
going to another place today to test it
out I forgot the name but we're going
there but first step is we're getting
the coffee coffee coffee time cappuccino
numb them to Lyndon and then our brains
will start working my brain still wakes
then my brain will start working your
job Nina
[Music]
we got our cappuccinos and we got a
special what do we get again take a bite
of the help zone nice
[Music]
all right we got a little lost trusting
in the Google API but it's okay because
we are close to the pecan Lodge
supposedly the best barbecue in Dallas
we're gonna have our morning barbecue
and see how it compares to what we went
to last night this place is so popular
that it has massive lineups up to a
couple hours I heard maybe that's
hyperbole I don't know look at that line
up around the corner hasn't even opened
yet hasn't even opened yet in his
earlier giant line all right let's go
stand in it Wow sweating their faces off
I told the admission should go inside a
local coffee shop to cool off and I'll
stand in line doesn't want to Joseph be
with me keep me company
it's hot it's the best if you touch
Nina's skin it I got a white book
somewhere
[Music]
the good news is or as long as this
crazy line is we got our spot and the
line just keeps on going now
everything's a little early at least
right we're moving then I remove any now
let's go means excited to try eight
pounds of brisket beginning an appetite
just want to try it
we're sitting in line just her taste to
biter two bites of brisket and then go
the lines moving fairly quickly what are
you shaking your hands for
I should have brought a water bottle it
could spray your back we're spraying you
with imaginary water did you feel it
Nina is it amazing
you got a fly on you
the check implies not okay and you're
like a horse just sweats attracting the
fly stay away flies
stay away this is the bulk order line
it's not us I mean it just wants a snack
oh I just ran how you only want half a
pound or something and what's what you
need eight eight five pounds look at
Nina trying to hack it I like it I like
it hacking the system good job
we've been standing in the Dallas heat
for 45 minutes Nina's very stoic and
we're happy because we're not at the
front of the line yet but we're at the
front of the line for the water mission
are you serious are you gonna water
she's being a germaphobe all right do
you want me to drink it I'll put it in
my mouth and then kiss you and give it
to you is that no okay well I'm gonna
get some water almost at the door it's
almost our turn
the lineup is real when our in we're
inside we get the stain in another line
[Music]
but the a/c is getting as happy
[Music]
what happened Nina brought a surprise
just for me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I always try the local beer
we're about the hoarder limas said she
only wanted half a pound of brisket the
same one case now we're getting the
three meat combo and a crazy wild wild
we're gonna walk out feeling
but I support it because we love Deena
okay
it is now 12:30 we got here no hope
dirty yes this 12:30 we got near 10:45
it's been almost two hours the food has
arrived the longest lineup we have ever
waited in for true
this is it moment of truth wasn't worth
it Nina was it worth it was it worth it
take the bite
and predicting a thumbs up
yeah so smokey is that a good one was it
worth waiting two hours yeah hesitation
but okay we're near we're good time to
eat yeah I got stopped by a fan love
wasn't many on the channel
okay
love your mother
a notepad by the
all right we are done how you feeling
Mina what full but not too full it's not
too crazy actually not too bad the
lineup is still ridiculous but it
doesn't feel is hot just me we're okay
Nina Nina does not want to update you
with how we're feeling she wants to move
on with her day so we are moving on with
our day to explore more of Dallas
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is some heat
they do not mess around in Dallas they
do not mess around we are melting pure
melt look at Nina can't even see anymore
we love you Nina I don't know I don't
know when you melt it looks like you
have to poo on the side of the street
another the heat is getting to our
brains I think we're not functioning as
proper humans anymore Dallas how do you
deal with this it's the best we are the
only ones walking on the street that's
what happens when you bring Canadians to
Dallas we walk out on the street and
melt is the best this is the best
[Music]
this cows drinking water makes me
thirsty makes me thirst because it's too
hot
this is what it feels like to be in the
middle of lots of cows done and cows get
wet move is that a joke move over that's
pretty cool all the calves
beautiful Dallas in the background
[Music]
we are in search of a coffee shop starve
to pass with lots of coffee shops
we're in search of a Starbucks because
Nina is melting melt a that male team so
everything closes here at 2 o'clock or
three o'clock and it's just past two
o'clock so we're rushing to find a
Starbucks that closes at 3:00 so we can
sit down for 30 minutes or so relax
enjoy some cold brew and some AC and
then continue on with the day
I see umbrellas oh but the umbrellas are
down that's not looking so promising
[Music]
what's it like sitting down Nina nice
cool chair in your butt you ready for
some cold drinks yeah thank you
Starbucks you love you feels better had
your drink you had your air conditioning
we sat inside
in 40 minutes we are going to continue
our last bits of the tour of Dallas and
then head back to our Airbnb
[Music]
I'm watching you Nina
[Music]
mm it's his team understand it you're
gonna see them soon
all right we made it are you feeling
okay how you feeling kitten it's
air-conditioned 15,000 sets it's not
that much so what's the plan now
you're gonna relax look at how you're
walking you so you're just gonna lie in
the bed and crash
you really are walking like an old woman
right we're gonna relax now ain't a
flying bed so we'll see you guys soon
yeah I'm coming okay it is just past six
o'clock the wife passed out had a crazy
nap you had a crazy it's our last meal
no no it's not true it's not true at all
it's our last dinner in Dallas and we're
gonna go to Bubba's for some prefer for
some country chicken something chicken
comfort food yes you could tell me but
just get up from a nap all right Bubba's
here we come
[Music]
here we are
Bubba's legendary chicken also
apparently good catfish mashed potatoes
banana pudding let's see what we get a
little small joint here but got amazing
ratings for Dallas so Bubba's give us a
feast
[Music]
so doesn't look the most appealing but
there it is
[Music]
not impressed just like a medium medium
is our first medium of the day our last
dinner in Dallas is a medium alright
let's see how the catfish is when it
comes all right catfish has arrived
Neena looks very excited to do all right
let's try it
catfish time
better than the chicken better than
chicken mer right okay this is a banana
pudding when you give it a Chinese Evan
are you gonna give it that I couldn't be
on camera
hey guys how you watching does it smell
good
the best part
are you feeling I am so full you're hot
I'm full we're hot full full hot I feel
gross
we're gonna do a bit of walking you know
look at the flowers they're taller than
you but you're prettier than them okay
wow that's um that's a Nina confidence
that's a character right there Nina look
at those flowers I'm prettier than them
Nina look at that sunset it's taller
than you but you're prettier Wow I'm
brighter I don't know actually
that's pretty bright I'm kind of blinded
oh I don't want to be blinded looking at
you because that that's that's a lot of
looking I don't want to have to wear
sunglasses every day of my life looking
at you though you're just enough
brightness not too much how about that
okay
[Music]
thank you for joining us in another day
in Dallas if you want to see us get a
private tour of Patrick be David's
office go check out the video right next
to us
I think you'll enjoy it continue to and
we'll see is there